One of the strengths of Gradle lies
in it's extensible domain model.
At the heart of this model
is the concept of tasks.
A task is a self-contained unit of
work that Gradle can reason about.
At the core of a task is its action, for
example we might declare a task
to compile some Java sources or
to copy some files from one directory
to another, or to simply print hello.
A task can perform some
action in isolation but
it can also declare
dependencies on other tasks.
Gradle will ensure that all
these dependencies are run and
ensure all of their dependencies and
so on and so on.
A task can also define its inputs and
its outputs, the files that
it reads from and writes to.
This allows Gradle to determine if
a task needs to do its work, or
if everything is already up to date,
in which case it doesn't need to run.
We'll explore all these features
later on in this lesson, but for
now let's get Gradle up and
running and execute our first task.